a big thank you to house party for
sponsoring this episode
if you don't know house party is a
really awesome app that allows up to 8
people to chat face to face so even
though we're all self isolating we are
staying in touch with house party can do
a lot of cool things like play games oh
he was in Twilight no other dude if you
don't have it make sure to download it
there is a link in the description below
and without further ado here's ask me
anything when people hear about it
what kind of stereotypes do people
automatically think of that I'm a thief
I thought I was being selfish that if I
loved my children I wouldn't have done
what I did some topics are hard to
approach the u.s. locks more people up
than any other country either the
subjects are inaccessible but people are
uncomfortable discussing them so we
found those subjects in person
rented a space in Los Angeles and
invited our audience and strangers to
come in and ask them anything
hi my name's Michelle and I'm an
ex-offender I'm here to answer questions
on the topic hey my name is Eric how you
doing I'm doing great thank you alright
I'm Michelle and it's great to meet you
it's great to meet you what was your
crime
white collar my situation was you know
writing checks I was involved in an
embezzlement case because of our system
back taxes and tax fraud and all these
other titles came with it what led you
to do what you did you know when it
started it actually was more of looking
out for my kids and my family give them
things that I felt they needed and
looking back I see that they didn't need
it and I caused more harm with a lot of
the encouragement youth I work with some
of them say if I could have gotten away
with this yeah I totally would have done
it again but I got caught do you feel
that something that you might have told
yourself five years ago I want to say no
because I think it's the right thing to
say however if I wouldn't it got caught
I probably would have continued to keep
doing it but for the most part I'm glad
that I got caught and I never want to go
back to it again what did you do for fun
in prison I don't know if I really did
anything for fun but I sure did learn a
lot of things I learned how to thread my
eyebrows with the string from new
tampons I learned how to cook some
really nice dinners with trash bags and
boiling water
have you seen orange is the new black no
what is that it's a show about women in
prison and what you're describing
there's like some portions where they do
the exact same thing yes I haven't
watched the show and I know I've been
I've been watched it okay I get asked
quite a bit so I you know I will answer
to the fact that there are very similar
traits the connection and relationship
with you have with the women in there
you know I had some really good friends
in there but there's also a lot of
Hollywood hype to it that it's not like
that
how long were you in prison for nearly
six years I was sentenced to ten years
and four months and I earned some time
off my sentence for good behavior if you
were in the jury for your case would you
have given yourself the same sentence
the lesser sentence or a longer sentence
and if you can justify why you know in
some ways I want to say that it was a
bit much
especially when the very same day I was
sentenced somebody else was sentenced
for a sex crime on a minor and got less
time than me
I remember reading that in the newspaper
and just being that you just totally
take him back you know like where's the
fairness in this but with that I will
also say that there's so many things
that I did do that I didn't get caught
for that the things I got blamed for
that I didn't do I had to just accept
what was the life like in the prison was
frightful I saw things that I thought
only happened in movies you know my
experience was added trauma but it also
is where a strengthened me came that I
would have never gotten anywhere else
was there a specific breaking point yeah
it's the combination you know first
being arrested than being in County Jail
for a year and a half and in jail
you only get enclosed visits no physical
contact
so for 18 months I wasn't able to touch
my children or hug them or have any
connection with them whatsoever except
words through a glass window
and if there was one thing you could
change about prison in general what
would that be the way that women are
treated in there
and the way they're looked at after a
visit with your children that your being
nurturing and loving you have to go in a
room and be strip-searched and you have
to bend over and you have to cough and
you have to just be humiliated after you
were just hugging and nurturing your
children and I'm talking minutes like
there's no time to shake off what you
just were and transform into the
prisoner you know no of course it's
dehumanizing yeah
how have you recovered or has it been
hard for you mentally yeah actually it's
been the biggest struggle of being a
previously incarcerated is coming home
and transitioning back into being a
human being back to into being a mother
to a wife it's quite challenging and
I've been home almost nine years and I
still battle like you know the shame and
the guilt from it but I've also take
great pride and the strives that I have
make to overcome some of it what is some
advice for people thinking of committing
a crime
obviously I want to say don't do it and
I don't mean that lightheartedly like
seriously it is just if I would have
known the severity of my consequences if
I would have seen the impact that it was
gonna have on other people's lives
especially my family I would really just
stop it and encourage that person to
think things through and if you can't
imagine what its gonna be like let me
introduce you to some friends who can is
there something you would tell your kids
the one thing that I have said that
I feel like I always want to keep saying
over and over is I'm sorry I'm sorry
that I hurt you I'm sorry that it caused
the pain that I caused you as a child
and as someone with parents who make
mistakes maybe not as large as yours I
do want to say that kids have this room
for forgiveness that is so much larger
only to their parents and I truly
believe that your kids will come to
accept and love you even more than they
did before I believe that there is of
course room for growth and room for
change and I believe that you will get
to a point where you and your family can
come together thank you thank you thank
you so much thanks for watching another
episode of asking anything and thank you
to epic games for sponsoring this
episode the people behind house party
check it out it's a free app you can
check up to eight people let's let's
just do this let's Jason Lee let's get
Jason on here let's see what happens
boom the power of house party you can
chat with your friends you can play
games we got heads up trivia chips and
guac quick draw we are all enjoying it
and using it a Jubilee during our time
and self isolation so make sure to check
it out thanks for watching see ya